Alex Rodriguez cheers on Jennifer Lopez
during her concert in NYC he loves it
[Music]
JLo sure seems to have the biggest fan
in boyfriend a rod the 47 year old
singer performed her new single in
Hunters Point Park in New York Friday
night during an epic fourth of July
celebration while Alex watched on and
snapped plenty of pics he's such a
supportive person Jenni paid homage to
her former pro baseball playing beau
while on stage rocking a rhinestone
Yankee hats
[Music]
the couple were photographed staring
lovingly at one another as they entered
the event hand in hand
JLo rocking a gorgeous black gown with
gold detailing and thigh high slits
while Alex donned an all-white ensemble
and blue tennis shoes for the occasion
and the 41 year old former Yankee star
gave Jennifer a congratulatory kiss as
she exited the stage and it was steamy
ahead of the show the couple squeezed in
a cuddle session oppo stood this
adorable pic of the pair cozied up
together on her tour bus captioning the
pic hashtag pre-show
[Music]
you